on April 21st jurgen schmidhuber tweeted
out stop crediting the wrong people for
inventions made by others at least in
science the facts will always win at the
end as long as the facts have not yet
won it is not yet the end no fancy award
can ever change that
hashtag it self-correcting science
hashtag plagiarism and links to an
article of his own website where he
wrote critique of Honda Prize for dr.
Hinton so this is on Schmidt Hoover's
own website and it's by himself and
don't you love this how to pronounce his
name
jurgen schmidhuber you again sorry this
is this is absolutely great so both
actually
Schmid over and Hinton are on Twitter
you can tweet at them and follow them
this article here is a basically a
critique of the press release of Honda
when they awarded geoff hinton for his
achievements and it goes through it step
by step and we won't look at the whole
thing but just two for you to get the
flavor so here honda says dr. Hinton has
created a number of technologies that
have enabled the broader application of
AI including the backpropagation
algorithm that forms the basis of deep
learning approach to AI and schmidhuber
just goes off its he basically claims
him while Hinton and his co-workers have
made certain significant contributions
to deep learning he claimed above is
plain wrong right he did not invent back
propagation the person who invented back
propagation was settled in linear MA and
the many papers he says basically many
papers failed to cite linin MA and this
who was the original inventor of back
prop and so on and he go kind of goes
through a history of this and how it's
even earlier I always have a bit of a
trouble with claims like who invented
what because when it is an algo
them really the same thing right and
when he when is it a variation on
another algorithm and when is it
something completely new it's never
entirely clear but the the points here
made that the things the backpropagation
algorithm existed before Hinton and also
that some of the papers some of the
seminal papers did not cite the correct
origin statement to in 2002 he
introduced the a fast learning algorithm
for restricted Boltzmann machines that
allowed them to learn a single layer of
distributor representation without
requiring any labeled data these methods
allow deep learning to work better and
they led to the current deep learning
revolution and he is no dr. Hinton's
interesting unsupervised pre training
for deep neural networks was irrelevant
for the current latif learning
revolution in 2010 our team showed that
the feed-forward networks can be trained
by plain backprop do not at all require
pre training and he basically again says
apart from this Hinton's unsupervised
pretending was conceptually a rehash of
my unsupervised pre training for deep
recurrent neural networks so he you know
as you know she made Ober has done a lot
of work in recurrent neural networks and
he basically says it it was just a
rehash of his algorithm now I I have to
say I have so first look first of all he
he makes a point here right that we
don't really do unsupervised
pre-training him or until now of course
but you like for to train an amnesty law
fighter you don't have to do that but
it's also doubtful that this this was a
step even though even if it wasn't on
the exact path to the current situation
it was a thing that got people excited
maybe
and so the critique is like half valid
and also it doesn't help me to burn that
he always compares it to his own things
like it just it just like either
criticized them for you know in general
things
but then avoid bringing your own things
in because it just sounds like I did
this before and also I read some papers
from from these times people just wrote
papers sometimes I haven't read this
specific one but sometimes people just
wrote papers writing down their ideas
like one could do this and this and this
never doing any experiments or actually
specifying exactly what they mean they
just kind of wrote down a bunch of ideas
and that got published especially like
there's some some reinforcement learning
papers where people are just like oh one
I imagine agents doing this and learning
from that so it is again it is never
really clear in ideas or just had by
everyone I think people people mistake
this that think that the ideas are
unique it's not ideas that are unique
many people have the same ideas but some
there's also execution and exact
formalization and so on and exact level
of specificity this all of this is
really hard
and then the honda says in 2009 dr.
Hinton and two of his students used
multi-layer neural nets to make major
breakthrough and speech recognition that
led directly to greatly improved and
this of course Schrader who goes off by
this because speech recognition is of
course prime LS TM territory so you
don't want to go near this and the Honda
further says revolutionized computer
vision by showing that deep learning
worked far better than existing state of
the art and again he says the basic
ingredients were already there and so on
and the our team in Switzerland already
used his first superior award-winning
GPU based CNN and so on that's what it's
called dan net was produced by his group
and again this seems correct right this
seems when he lays it out like this but
it doesn't change the fact that Alex
net1 imagenet in 2012 and that was like
the start of
the deep learning revolution it was like
wow you can cut the learn like the error
rate by something like 30% simply by
doing this deep learning stuff so again
even if Dan that he says it blew away
the competition
it just seems it it always seems like
Schmidt Hooper's kinda right but then
also he's not he's like a cadet exact
academic work and and the idea being
there on a paper isn't the only thing
that drives progress and says to achieve
their dramatic results dr. Hinton also
invented a widely used new method called
dropout which reduces overfitting no
like no and like no just no like
randomly dropping parts in order to make
something more robust that is surely not
a new thing and he also says much early
it is there's this stochastic Delta rule
and so on and he also critiques that
this paper did not cite this they just
gave it the name right this is an idea
that is kind of so simple that you you
wouldn't even necessarily think about
researching whether that has existed
already I think they just did it and
then because it's a natural idea and
then they gave it a name and the name
stuck right it's not about the idea
itself and then lastly they say of the
countless AI based technological
services across the world it is no
exaggeration to say that few would have
been possible without the results dr.
Hinton created I love this name one that
would not have been possible and he just
gives a list of their own group and that
are basically possible without Hinton's
contributions and this is just it's a
bit of a cheap shot right clearly honda
if they're not saying it would have been
you know physically him
possible without his contributions its
but certainly Hinton has has if even if
he hadn't invented any of those things
he certainly has created like a spark
and his these things created a splash
got people excited people thinking about
new ways of applying things even you
know if this is all true so right and
but but I would like you to I'd like you
to notice this is a critique of what
Honda says about Hinton and if I read
through the statements of Schmidt who
were most of them are technically
correct right and you know that so that
was that and then I thought okay cool
but then someone posted II didn't read
it and then Hinton replies and this is
okay don't you love this so Hinton says
having a public debate with schmidhuber
about academic credit is not at
advisable because it just encourages him
and there is no limit to the time and
effort that he is willing to put into
trying to discredit his perceived
Arrivals he is even escorted to tricks
like having multiple aliases in
Wikipedia to make it look as if other
people agree the patient on his website
about Alan Turing is a nice example of
how he goes on trying to these are like
these are shots fired and he says I'm
going to respond once and only once I
have never claimed that I invented
backpropagation David Romo hard invented
it independently after other after other
people in other fields had invented it
it's true when you first published we
did not know the history so he basically
says okay we did forget decided when we
first published about rock crop but he
doesn't say he invented it what I've
claimed is that I was the person to
clearly demonstrate that back prop could
learn interesting in turn represent
and that that this is what made it
popular right so this goes into into the
direction schmidhuber is very much on
academic contributions idea was there
before and hint and basically says no
what we did is kind of we showed that it
works in this particular way and we can
have got people excited about it I did
is by forcing that blah blah blah and it
is he says it is true that many people
in the press have said I invented back
prop and I've spent a lot of time
correcting them here's an excerpt from
2018 where this is I guess a quote from
this book that quotes Hinton where he
says lots of people invented different
versions of back prop before day with
normal heart they were mainly
independent inventions something I feel
I've got too much credit for it's one of
these rare cases where an academic feels
he has got too much credit for something
my main contribution was to sure you can
use it for learning distributed
representations so I'd like to set the
record straight on that and then he said
maybe Jurgen would like to set the
record straight on who invented LST M's
boom boom crazy shot shots fired by
Hinton here this is I mean this is just
great
but again look at what Hinton says
Hinton basically says yes I have not
invented that I have corrected this on
public record in the past and yeah so so
that's what Hinton says and I mean the
the the comments here are just gold I
really invite you to read it and then
schmidhuber of course being Schmidt who
replies again down here he has a a
response to the reply and I don't expect
Hinton to reply again so I waited for a
bit but but I I believe him when he says
he does it only once so he goes into
this summary the facts presented in
sections 1 2 3 4 5 are
still valid so he goes what kind of
statement by statements is having a
public debate blah blah blah and he says
this is an ad hominem attack which is
true right this is true and he says he
even has multiple aliases in Wikipedia
and he just says another ad hominem
attack and then he goes into that
schmidhuber tries to discredit Alan
Turing and then shmita goes into this
big long big long basically claim that
Alan Turing wasn't as important as
people made him out to be and people
invented this kind of
Turing machine equivalents before that
again it's kind of showing tubers take
that the idea basically was already
there and these people don't get the
correct credit and also he's correct
that this is a this is a true it's an ad
hominem attack right so you know be it
as it may this is correct and then when
when Hinton goes that he doesn't stay
and invent backdrop and me to persist
this is finally response related to my
post which is true right however he does
not at all contradict what I wrote and
it is true that he credited his
co-author Rommel Hart with the invention
but but neither cited alanine MA and
also the statement
lots of people he says it wasn't created
by lots of different people but exactly
one person so this I find como
like can you really say now this is the
exact time when backprop was invented
even though it probably wasn't in the
current exact current formulation and it
probably existed someone like this so
but again and he his main claim is dr.
Hinton except the Honda Prize although
he apparently agrees that Honda's claims
are false he should ask Honda to correct
their statements and
like in the end maybe you're going would
like to set the record straight who
invented LST M's and you know as we as
you may know seppo writer it kind of
invented LST ms under jurgen schmidhuber
as a as a PhD advisor but the to
summarize dr. Hinton's comments and ad
hominem arguments diverged from the
contents of my post and do not challenge
the facts and so on and i have to say
after reading this this this is a this
is correct right hinton basically
replies to hey i I never claimed I
invented back prop and other people have
invented it and Schmidt Hoover doesn't
criticize hinton in this particular post
he may otherwise schmidhuber doesn't
create as as Hinton for claiming that he
criticizes Honda for claiming that
Hinton did and it doesn't hidden
basically agrees with him and also
schmidhuber says dr. Hinton accepted the
Honda Prize although he apparently
agrees that the claims are false he
should ask Honda to correct their
statements and it is true that Hinton
accepted this price under this release
right now you might be able to say him
Hinton also says he's on the record
basically saying he didn't do this and I
guess if you're Hinton and you know
you've had this you've had a successful
career and so on and you have previously
really publicly stated that you didn't
invent these things and you know made it
clear and then you get a prize and they
write this thing maybe you just don't
want to go after every single press
statement and correcting that but you
know in essence basically Hinton and
understood this as an attack on himself
that he claims he invented back prop and
schmidhuber says Honda claims he
invented back rub and Hinton accepted
the price so agrees with it and he
basically agrees with it but doesn't say
Honda should have corrected at which I
can understand so this is my take on
this issue it's kind of both or
correct and they just kind of talk past
each other and schmidhuber is always on
the the idea existed before and Hinton
is correct when he says it's not always
just about the idea progress is also
made by people being excited people
actually getting something to work
people you know doing something at the
right time in the right place which is
also correct but it is fun it is fun so
so I just I enjoyed I enjoy this
honestly like because ultimately this is
the kind of discussions also need to
happen in science because credit
assignment is an important thing in
science and even though sometimes it's
over the top like schmidhuber always
going after it I think we need people
like him just kind of to keep the field
in check a bit and yeah I will link to
all of this I hope you enjoy this and I
wish you nice rest of the weekend if
you're still here consider subscribing
and leave comment if you want I really
read them bye bye